nuclear terrorism is how an iranian
official
described a power blackout at its natanz
nuclear enrichment facility
but it stopped short of blaming any
group or country
sunday's cut in the electrical supply
grid caused no casualties or
contamination
terrorist incident in chance following
the incident and the turns nuclear
facility this morning
the head of the atomic energy department
called this a terrorist move and
emphasize on the necessity of response
by international bodies
and the iaea to this act of nuclear
terrorism
israeli media claimed it was caused by a
cyber attack
launched by israeli security services
although it quoted unidentified sources
some media outlets have a close
relationship with intelligence agencies
iran is now urging the international
atomic energy agency to take action
saying it reserves the right to punish
the perpetrators
the development comes at an important
time as iran prepares to step back to
the negotiating table in vienna
talks about iran's nuclear agreement
started there last week
with indirect talks with the united
states
president joe biden says he's willing to
rescue a deal abandoned three years ago
by his predecessor donald trump that is
if iran comes into compliance with the
deal
in my view without a doubt this is
definitely not a coincidence
and one thing you need to remember while
it is uh
israel is the usual suspect in these
events over the last few years
one must be mindful there there are many
opponents in many different corners
to the resumption of the joint
comprehensive plan of action
not the least of which is from within
iran itself tehran has been steadily
moving away from the terms of the 2015
nuclear deal
since the u.s pulled out the blackout
happened a day after iran unveiled
advanced uranium centrifuges at the
facility
but iran had previously made clear that
negotiations in vienna
are on the right track laura berger
manly al-jazeera